[Music]
an easy way to make your app more
polished is to implement animations
between router transitions today's video
is a complete guide to router animations
in angular and we'll build four
different styles that range from a
simple fade into a complex keyframe
sequence of animations if you're new
here like and subscribe and grab the
full source code from fire ship IO and
before we get started I want to give a
quick shout out to the deal crunch app
which is a real estate app available on
iOS and Android it was built by one of
our pro members and is a great example
of what you can do with angular and
ionic now let's first start by looking
at the actual animations that we'll
build in this video the first one is
just a simple fade in which is applied
to every single route in the app the
second animation is a slide from left to
right and it determines which direction
to slide based on data that we pass in
through the router configuration the
third one is slightly more complex and
adds and transformations so we can make
the page kind of rotate in from the top
corners and the fourth and final one
uses keyframes to create a sequence of
style changes for example the new page
comes in from the bottom and bumps the
old page off and it spins and scales out
of the screen I'm starting off here in
my angular 7 app and you'll notice that
I've generated a handful of components
here just so we have something to
actually route to and you don't need to
do anything special with these
components whatsoever so we won't even
bother looking at them in this video
then the other thing we'll do in the app
module is import the browser animations
module and add it to the imports array
from there we'll go into the HTML on the
app component and create a main element
and then define an animation called
route animations and then we'll point
this to a method called prepare route
which will define in a second and it's
job is to determine which animation to
apply to a given route now inside of
this element we'll define our router
outlet and then give it a template
variable name of outlet as well now
whenever a route changes we can animate
the content inside of the router outlet
then you can see above the outlet I have
my actual navigation bar so this will
stay fixed and not be animated between
the route changes now we'll jump into
the app component type script and you'll
see that I'm importing these animations
which we have not yet defined I simply
want to point out that we'll be adding
these to the animation property in the
component decorator and you can just
uncomment whichever animation that you
want to use here in our case we're going
to be defining different animations for
different routes so we need to create
this prepare route method to
pass in that dynamic data this is
actually taken directly from the angular
Doc's and it's technically optional if
you're only using a single animation for
every route in that case you could pass
the outlet to the animation directly in
the HTML the last thing we want to do is
go into our router configuration and
you'll see we have three routes set up
each one just pointing to a component
when we get to our slider animation will
need to determine if a component should
slide in from the left or slide in from
the right we can do this by passing in a
data attribute and we'll give it a name
of animation then we'll define
animations named is right and is left
now that prepare wrap method that we
defined earlier we'll look for this
property and then apply the
corresponding animation the next thing
I'm going to do is create a file called
route animations ts in the app directory
and then we'll basically import
everything under the kitchen sink from
angular animations the first animation
we'll build is the most basic use case
which is just a standard animation that
gets applied to every route change
notice we give the trigger a name of
route animations that must match what
you entered in the HTML the next thing
we'll do is define a transition which
determines how to apply styles from one
animation to the next in this case we're
using the star arrow syntax to define a
wild car that will apply to every single
route transition angular animations will
apply to pseudo selectors to the
elements that were animating one called
enter and one called leave so enter is
the new page leave is the old page and
query allows us to actually select these
elements from the Dom so the first step
in the transition is to prepare these
elements so they can be animated to do
that effectively we'll position them as
absolute and then we'll also bring the
opacity down to zero and then translate
them off the screen and scale them down
to zero so basically with this step
we're just creating a starting point
from which we can use to animate in the
new page and at the same time we're
immediately hiding the old page so
angular animations will apply these
steps in the transition one after the
other so at this point we've styled our
elements both to be hidden now we need
to animate in the new page we can do
that by making a query for the enter
selector which again is the new page and
then we'll animate that in but first I
want to point out that I had to go into
the style.css and set the main element
to position:relative this just ensures
that you have a consistent style between
the page transitions now back to our
animation we've queried for the enter
selector then we'll use the animate
method to set up the actual transition
we'll give it a timing of six
milliseconds with the ease function then
we'll define a style that is basically
the end point of the animation so from
our starting point we'll want to set the
opacity to one scale it to one and then
set the y-axis translation to zero
so just to recap the entire animation we
start by hiding both the old and new
components didn't we fade in the new
component over the course of six hundred
milliseconds the end result looks like
this and the same animation is applied
to every route change but you'll notice
our layout has both a right page and a
left page so there's sort of a concept
of position within this layout in the
next animation will actually take into
account the position and do a different
animation based on whether or not the
component is on the right or the left
now I'm defining a function called slide
two which will allow us to reuse a lot
of the same logic for both the left and
right transitions this animation has
multiple transition possibilities and
that's based on the dynamic data that
we're passing in through the router
config so any component that transitions
to the is left animation will slide to
the left and conversely any component
going to the right will slide to the
right then our middle component doesn't
have any animation data defined at all
so we'll also want to set up transitions
anytime that we're going from the is
right animation just to any component
that means that we should be moving to
the left so we'll go ahead and use the
slide to the left animation and lastly
we'll do the same thing for the opposite
and now we'll define the actual slide to
function I'm setting up a variable for
optional here because some of these
queries will want to be optional in case
the actual leaving component isn't
present then just like we did before
we'll set up some default styles here in
this case we don't want to actually hide
the elements but we'll just make them
position:absolute and at the top of the
page and then will dynamically pass in
the direction which can either be right
or left
so those styles are applied to both
components but we want to add an
additional style to only the entering
component which will offset it in either
direction 100% from its sibling
component at this point we have two
different components that we want to
animate and we want those to happen at
the same time which is why we add them
to a group otherwise they would happen
one after the other we can start with
the animation for the leaving component
in this case we'll go ahead and animate
it 100% off the screen so that will move
it in the opposite direction of the
starting point from the entering
component then to animate the entering
component we'll just go ahead and set
its direction to 0% which will put it
right in the middle where it's supposed
to be and you'll also notice that
both of the animations have the same
timing function and the end result is
just a smooth sliding animation from
left to right but let's go ahead and we
want to transition number three which is
just a variation on this last one but
instead uses CSS transforms this allows
us to achieve that same sliding effect
but we can also do cool things like
rotation or scaling or whatever else we
want to add in here well start with the
same basic setup as last time and we'll
define triggers that go from left to
right but this time you'll notice we're
passing in a bunch of named arguments so
our function will take an x value a Y
value and also a rotation value so my
goal here is basically to give you a
function that you can configure with
your own arguments to create a whole
bunch of different crazy animations now
if we go down to the actual function you
can see that I'm using D structuring to
add named arguments to this function
with default values that's just some
useful syntactic sugar if you have a
single object as an argument that has
default values again we'll start this
animation off by styling the enter and
leave components then we can define our
transformations by simply interpolating
values into strings for example we can
add x and y values to translate as
percentages and then a rotation value as
degrees for rotate and you can even
extend this with skew and scale or
whatever other transformations you want
to use now if we skip ahead here to the
animations they're pretty much identical
to the previous example except we're
adding the values and here for the
transforms instead of the direction now
we're going to switch gears and look at
a keyframed animation currently all of
our animations use a transition which
basically just has a single starting
point and ending point but in many cases
with animations you have multiple
intermediate steps that can't be defined
by just a single start and end point so
let's go ahead and define a new
animation that just uses the wild-card
to apply the same animation to every
route then like every other animation
we'll set the initial position to
absolute then we'll also set up a group
to run the two page animations
concurrently then in all the previous
examples we just animate it to a single
style and this example will use the
keyframes function to pass in an array
of styles you can think of these styles
as steps in your animation and you
determine where they happen based on the
total time by setting an offset value so
an offset of 0 will apply the style as
soon as the animation starts since we're
working with the enter component we'll
go ahead and scale it to 0 and translate
it off the page
then we'll add a second style with an
offset of 0.3 which for a 2000
millisecond animation would be 600
milliseconds in other words this style
will be applied to the element at 30% of
its animation lifecycle and we'll finish
things up by setting a final style with
an offset of 1 which is the end of the
animation and that will be when the
component is fully visible at a scale of
1 and a translate of 0
now we'll go down here to the leaf
component and try to roughly match the
keyframes to the entering component we
want to achieve an effect that makes it
look like the entering component bumps
the old component off the screen we can
achieve that by scaling it up to 600
percent of its original size while at
the same time rotating it and fading it
out to an opacity of 0 the end result is
this 3d effect of the pages looking like
they're colliding hopefully this video
give you an idea of what is possible
with angular router animations so you
can start building your own beautiful
transitions between pages in your app
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and make sure to grab
the full source code at fire ship IO
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]